>> So the tools that I was talking about
you can find those owasp.org website.
So remember we're talking about
source code analysis tools here.
So we are making assumption that the
code that you write, you have the source
code and you want to make sure that it
doesn't have those vulnerabilities.
So you going to run it, so
you obviously have the source code.
You run it through these tools.
A lot of times if the code
is not written by you,
it's coming from somebody else.
You may only have the binary.
And then some of those tools
that requires source code,
reduce source code analysis
obviously won't be helpful.
So discovering those vulnerability and
binary is said reverse engineering and
all the other skills come in,
but attackers for
example will take binary code and
try to discover vulnerabilities in it.
And we do that,
one of the lab courses we teach here.
People with attackers mindset,
given a piece of binary how do you find
out if has let's say, some potential
overflow kind of vulnerability or not.
But if your source code,
you writing the code and
you want to deliver secure coding and
so on.
If you work for a company part of
their software development process may
include reviews and passing those codes
through these kind of tools and so on.
It's a problem that we all recognize,
we all recognize the importance
of writing secure code.
And these analysis tools can help you
identify potential vulnerabilities and
mistakes that you may have made.
That could result into these kind of
things that we've been talking about.
So, spending a little bit of time
with these is a good idea and
that's going to help you
write more secure code.